my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone I'm Alana ochar alanazada
and welcome to my gaming Channel slash
entertainment Channel I'm kind of making
it a little bit broader because we've
been doing movie reviews I might do some
TV stuff too um this is gonna be my last
q a on this channel you know I've been
doing them for like a decade literally a
decade worth of of Q and A's on here and
at this point I'm so certain that I
answer the same questions over and over
again I am going to continue doing Q and
A's on my Vlog Channel my personal
Channel which is youtube.com Alana IRL
is also linked in the description this
is the last gaming one you can ask
gaming questions over there now so thank
you everybody who's asked me questions
here for the last decade they just
started to get similar and I wanted to
free myself of the like required upload
each month and instead just jump into
like fun news topics whenever like I
kind of have been recently with the
destiny 2 video or the Russian Clank
video like more directly on topic stuff
so for our final questions patch 100
said hey Alana just wondering what some
of your least favorite recent Trends in
game development are I assume that you
don't literally mean in game development
I assume you mean in video games that
have come out least favorite Trends
obviously
I've said many a year now that I'm not a
fan of micro transactions
um that's a really easy boring one
though otherwise I think we have a lot
of bloat in a lot of games right now I
don't think that every game needs to be
everything I think there are a lot of
games that have
um RPG mechanics that don't necessarily
benefit from RPG mechanics like crafting
or or certain level systems I think
there are also a lot of games that come
out that are a lot longer than they need
to be I don't think every game needs to
be 50 100 hours they're just across the
board a lot of a lot of bloat
um which maybe is an unpopular opinion
you know that could very well be a
result of Gamers saying that they want
more value for money or bigger or you
know more things but I've always hated
the phrase of like next time it's gonna
be bigger and better I'm like what if it
was just better why does it need to be
bigger we don't have to make everything
bigger all the time it's too much video
game I think I also so dislike um a sort
of homogenization of a lot of writing uh
I think there have been a lot of AAA
titles where the writing is almost
interchangeable in that it's so similar
uh everyone's kind of quippy and Kraken
marvel-esque jokes and I don't doubt
that that inspiration does come directly
from Marvel but I think when you have
like so many video game franchises where
so many of your characters feel like
that they could be in any of those
things because everything's that they
just have similar speech patterns and
they all sound like they walked out of a
Marvel film not a huge fan of that
either but similarly part of the job's
got to be going where people seem to
respond right where Gamers seem to enjoy
things so it's not super simple but yeah
blood would be my biggest one I like
things sticking to their genre and
really nailing their genre rather than
trying to do and be everything I feel
like that uh leads to a better quality
experience Stephen Summers said any
gaming franchises you want to write or
think that you could add an interesting
perspective on
I'm so sure I've answered this one
before but it's also like probably one
of the most common questions that I get
asked I don't care about what franchisor
IP I work on quite as much as I care
about the team I work on so I care a lot
about like working with a bunch of
people who I find like very inspiring
and very talented and very experienced
because that way I can learn from them
and that appeals to me more than like
getting to write on one of my favorite
franchises because not that God of War
isn't I mean very clear before I join
SMS that I'm a big fan of their games
but um it means that I don't get to
enjoy those games anymore in a way like
it's not like I don't but it's a very
different thing now so if there are
franchises or IPS that I love
um and I'm not writing on them it's kind
of a positive because it means that I
still just get to enjoy them like
anybody else does there are definitely
downsides to working on franchises that
you love but uh if I'm learning anything
from the several years that I've been in
Dev it's that I really love horror I
know I do I'm always like what if it was
scary and I do it by accident all the
time or like I pitched something that is
just inherently creepy like it just I'm
survival horror is my favorite genre of
video game I just like gravitate towards
it so I think I would probably really
enjoy working on a survival horror game
but only if my job role will like it is
now like maybe less so for scripting but
more from the design perspective
um in that like I get to pitch things
that are happening or what levels might
look like like that kind of stuff is is
just I so clearly want to do horror very
into it so I'm sure I would love that
um but yeah otherwise like nothing
specific in terms of Ip it is time to
talk about keeps which for any of you
who don't know is a subscription service
that helps men keep their hair before I
ever agreed to work with keeps I spoke
to a whole bunch of male friends who I
knew used it or had tried it in the past
and literally every single one of them
highly recommended it had great things
to say it was really strongly encouraged
to talk to you all about keeps as an
option for men who might be insecure
about going bold it's really common
actually two out of three guys will
experience help us by the time they're
35 but because the way that keeps works
it can prevent further hair loss and
help you keep and take better care of
the hair that you might have some very
important things to know about keeps one
all keeps treatments plans are
recommended by a licensed medical
provider they have a network of Expert
Medical advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality actually each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about pretty
much anything and at any time two is
that it's really easy to get it's
delivered straight to your door so there
are no waiting lines at pharmacies no
awkward doctor visits they make it as
reliable and pain-free as possible and
lastly they have incredibly positive
reviews across the board so not just the
friends that I mentioned but user
reviews across the internet are
extremely positive regarding keeps I
mean check out these before and after
photos it kind of speaks for itself
hello stops with keeps to get a special
offer go to keeps.com Alana Pierce or
click the link in the description that
is k-e-p-s.com Alana Pierce now back to
the video did you get the Spider-Man
PS5 I you did not get the PS5 I did get
the collectors edition and I'm really
excited about it
um I'll probably do an unboxing on here
and then actually give it away I've been
trying to like buy collected editions
and then do giveaways as uh incentives
to raise more money for charity which
has been tons of fun I'm actually giving
away the Starfield headset on Twitch
right now this one right here oh my God
because it's mirrored I did a really bad
job of pointing that this one right here
yeah Spider-Man 2 is definitely also up
there for my most anticipated games of
the year I mean I'm gonna be honest I
think the 2023 has turned out to be like
a very good year for video games okay
surprisingly good yeah I don't know why
I didn't expect it it's the the new
Zelda came out but like Final Fantasy 16
as well that I've gotten to play a bit
more of that I've not finished it uh
pretty far off finishing it but like I
ended up liking it even more than I
expected to I was already excited but
then when I started playing I was like
man I do not like the amount of cut
scenes here and then I kept playing and
I was like you know what a lot of the
time I don't like it when cutscenes are
so frequent that they break up gameplay
I find that to be a little bit
frustrating and I always feel like you
know it's an appealing challenge of
video games is that you can tell the
story through gameplay it's an
interactive medium you can still give
players information and there's a ton of
Challenger challenges around that of
like what are they paying attention to
are they not going to listen because
they're engaged in an action are they on
their phones during cutscenes how long
did they go between finding out
information was it two weeks since the
last time they played how do I make sure
that they know what's happening like
when you don't control somebody's time
or actual attention like you can in a
film I think video game writing is way
harder than it like is recognized to be
you'll see so many people be like and
video game writing [__] anyway like I
feel like that's a common journalist
YouTuber take very few people
acknowledge the unique challenges video
games have compared to films and TV
though of like you literally cannot
control where somebody is looking or
their attention span people will
complain the story doesn't make sense to
them because they were texting or like
talking to their chat during a cut scene
you see what happened with twitch all
the time sure I'm like personally guilty
of that it's a real challenge I
literally don't remember what sparkling
on my trainer thought what was the
question I was answering just now
I don't remember hope that answered your
question curious if you have a take on
the negative reception from devs to
Baldur's Gate three yeah so Austin
mentioned this on the most recent
episode of players listen so I looked it
up and
I couldn't actually find
an example of a Dev who appeared to be
angry about the quality of Baldur's Gate
3. just a lot of people suggesting devs
were angry like I saw all these tweets
from like Gamers being like Oh Deb's
complaining that they're expected to
release a good quality video game but I
couldn't find the
um source of the anger I found one tweet
thread that didn't come across as it was
someone who was upset about baldus Gate
um it was more that they were like hey
Valerian had a really unique
um development
time process whatever and they did and
it is not the standard and that is true
and I'm not saying that they don't exist
I just couldn't couldn't find any of
those like Angry Dev tweets that I keep
hearing word of okay yeah not saying
they don't exist I just didn't see any
but um yeah what larian had is very
unique they had a lot of people 400
people is a lot of people for a
effectively an indie game a massive open
Beta previews like four years ago huge
Deb cycle it is not something that I
think players should expect and
um I do think the reception uh where
Gamers have been like this is what
happens when devs aren't lazy like is
shitty and and like nuts like I honestly
there's some tweets that I I found you
still call them tweets who knows uh this
one says I saved some of them this one
says oh no game dev's scared they may
have to deliver a good product the
horror and this is based on an IGN
headline uh developers freaking out
because they have to try well oh no
they're gonna expect us to make better
games is a hell of a take for some in
the games industry crash when and then
every triple a studio and people want to
make a good game and my whole thing
about that is like there is no Dev
Studio on the planet planet that wants
anything other than to make a good game
literally 100 of them I I do not believe
one exists as long as it's a legitimate
Dev Studio not a shovelware studio or a
literal like scam studio um of which
none in AAA are every Dev Studio
every person on that team all they want
is to make a good game and the
suggestion that they don't is absurd and
saying what Larry and were able to do
with baldus Gate 3 is not uh the
traditional Dev experience is is
accurate it's not an excuse it's just
what working with Publishers is they're
often not going to give you a budget or
a time frame uh Like Larry and we're
able to have with Ballers Gate 3 which
is obviously indicated in the quality
and my suggestion would certainly not be
to like get mad at devs which is the
only thing I have seen it's like a
couple people being like they can do it
Baldur's Gate three [__] all of you
other Dev Studios and I'm like that's
not the takeaway here all the other Dev
Studios don't have what what larian has
here and I recognize I'm saying this
like as someone who's like Loosely
informed on this situation I've not done
a ton of digging into this particular
thing or who's saying what you know I'm
not like it's not a drama that I want to
overly expose myself to so I haven't
read it all but I think basically that
was one Dev who was like please don't
harass people because Baldur's Gate 3
had this exception to the rule which I
think is like a totally fair take
Rockstar is pretty similar uh in that
because of the way that their
relationship works with take two and I
think I'm gonna make a video about just
Rockstar in general right now because
that the the way they've shifted in
conversation is really strange to me so
I might do like a little another like 15
minute just a chat about what Rockstar
is doing but like nobody gets video game
budgets and the amount of time and
resources that Rockstar does to make
video games like it's you can't look at
them and be like why isn't everybody
else doing this the answer is shortcuts
like if to make that exchange work for
every other Studio everyone would have
to make GTA online as well which game
was like complain about constantly and
you have to let uh your remakes be done
by different Studios which are also like
not of great quality but like that's how
they are given the resources to make the
games that they make or the caliber they
make them I imagine GTA 6 is going to be
incredible I'm so excited for any
Rockstar game like unlike any other
Studio on the planet I am excited for a
rockstar game it is a great time but
that yeah that situation is really
unique and I think that's similar to
larion and I think that's what that's
all that I've seen is anyone trying to
say but then yeah I saw this IGN video
it was by uh Destin whom I'm a fan of
who was like kind of hostile about
whatever Dev takes he had seen so it's
either I'm just not seeing these Dev
takes everyone's talking about I'm just
seeing people talk about them I couldn't
find any of them or I think people are
misunderstanding it's not Dev saying
like [__] Larry and nobody could do this
they don't deserve the credit or
whatever it's just an expression of like
the gamers who are criticizing
every other Studio because they can't
make something as massive as Baldur's
Gate 3. I think it's kind of worth
addressing why and that larion is in a
really unique position there but yeah I
don't want to take anything away from
them either they've clearly done
something incredible like it it's
unbelievable I'm so I'm still so early
in Boulder's Gate 3 and I feel like this
is like the video game of my dreams like
the amount of choice it's mind-blowing
it's so good and that is pretty much it
most of the comments on this one are
people discussing how they felt about
something came first
um so yeah I'm gonna leave it there
everybody thank you for the years of
submitting questions for Q and A's here
on this channel it's been fun I'm gonna
keep doing them on the IRL Channel where
you can't you can't ask me gaming
questions now we're just moving them
over I just think I kind of answered
them all here to be honest and I'm uh
I'm preferring spending the like the
time to make short videos on on like
quick and new stories I'm enjoying doing
that um whenever they pop up so that's
why we're gonna keep doing thank you all
so much for watching I'm Alana I'll see
you guys next time bye